so the pull out from Afghanistan under
Joe Biden was one of the most
humiliating foreign policy disasters in
American history it's hard to think of
one more humiliating 13 American
servicemen killed thousands of American
citizens Left Behind many Afghans died
by the way some of them fell off
airplanes others were blown up in drone
strikes for no obvious Reason by the
bite Administration and maybe worst of
all we turned the Taliban into the best
armed military force after Pakistan in
the entire region
Joe Biden did that his first summer as
president so what does the
administration have to say about this
well in a new report they take no
responsibility whatsoever instead they
blame it on somehow Donald Trump so
today Fox's Peter Ducey asked John Kirby
how does that make sense watch
you admit that the intel was bad so how
can President Biden ever trust when they
come into the Oval Office with the pdb
that anything in there is legit what I
said was that intelligence is a mosaic
what if the Mosaic all the pieces are
incorrect what I said was Intelligence
is hard business and they get it right a
lot too there were some pieces here that
weren't accurate this document and this
effort isn't about accountability today
this is the next muscle movement in what
will be a long process to better
understand and comprehend and adjust to
what we learned and what we did in
Afghanistan there were children being
killed there were people hanging off of
Air Force jets that were leaving and
you're saying that you guys are proud of
the way that this mission was conducted
it doesn't mean a bat proud of the fact
that we got more than 124 000 people
safely out of Afghanistan you bet proud
of the fact that we now have about a
hundred thousand afghans our former
allies and partners living in this
country and working towards citizenship
you bet does that mean that everything
went perfect in that evacuation of
course not
few things weren't degrading to the
reputation hard-earned reputation of the
American armed services than having a
Shameless liar like that man John Kirby
speaking on his behalf
Joe Ken carried a weapon in combat zones
for most of his life he's retired Green
Beret combat veteran also former
candidate for congress he joins us
tonight Joe Kent thank you so much for
coming on
um so what do you as someone who spent a
lot of his life in that region what do
you make of this explanation
well first off Tucker all the Democrats
and Joe Biden are trying to do right now
is avoid accountability shifted back to
president Trump and that's because House
Republicans have finally started putting
some pressure on the Biden
Administration demanding for
accountability so that's the the
knee-jerk reaction but this is a
complete and total disgrace look I would
have a lot more respect for the bite
Administration if they went after the
military industrial complex and the
intelligence Community for their lies
this all goes back to when President
Trump attempted to get us out of
Afghanistan he fought us to the
negotiations table and that's when the
intelligence community and the
military-industrial complex lied to the
American people they leaked it to the
media that there that Putin had put
bounties on the heads of American
soldiers the whole russian-bounding
narrative and then Congress in a
bipartisan fashion moved to block Trump
from spending money to get us out of
Afghanistan in the summer fall time
frame of 2020. we should have been out
then we had a plan but then Biden came
in and he couldn't do Trump's plan he
wanted to get our troops out on his
timeline in September 11th of 2021 and
the military industrial complex
continued to lie this time to Joe Biden
you kept hearing those Rosy assessments
of how the Afghan military was going to
hold the ground and they were going to
stand and fight for months on end they
lied and Americans died as a result
someone must be held accountable
yeah so you know what happened you
personally Joe can't know what happened
and almost uniquely are brave enough to
tell the truth about it and this is why
they prevented you from winning that
seat in Congress and one of the most
rotten elections I've ever seen and so I
hope you'll be running again and
continuing to tell the truth Joe Kent
thank you
thank you Tucker I will subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight